on apprenait cette semaine que les
institutions financières pourrait
permettre jusqu'à six mois de report des
paiements hypothécaires pour les clients
en difficulté ont joint au téléphone ce
soir guy cormier pdg de desjardins
bonsoir monsieur cormier bon temps le
pilier monsieur cormier ce que vos
clients qui ont du mal à payer leur
hypothèque pourront reporter leurs
paiements hypothécaires va écouter
actuellement le cas par cas là on prend
le temps parler avec chacun des
personnes qui communiquent avec nous ce
soient des particuliers notamment pour
la route hypothèque cartes de crédit et
dans certains cas oui en fonction de
leur condition on va pouvoir avoir un
report de paiement parfois favorable
pour les entreprises un moratoire
c'est vraiment le cas par cas ça nous
laisse quand même une forme de flou on
pourrait dire ça veut dire quoi c'est
quoi les conditions pour que ce soir les
gens qui nous écoutent se disent ah ben
voilà je suis dans une situation je
pourrais reporter à plus tard mais
paiements hypothécaires
la première chose qu'on regarde est ce
que la personne elle est affectée par le
co marquage du sort veut pas dire
qu'elle est malade personnellement
qu'elle a perdu son emploi parce qu'elle
n'est pas en arrêt de travail momentanée
kelly lequel son fils revenu durant cet
arrêt de travail or quelles sont les
dépenses peut-être exceptionnel qu'elle
a à a généré 6 être la conjointe ou le
conjoint travaille pendant comptera
vraiment est de regarder toutes les
situations vous savez aujourd'hui vous
avez des gens qui sont en arrêt de
travail mais qui continuent d'être payés
ou au complet de par parfois leurs
conditions de travail alors que d'autres
se sont vraiment des travailleurs
autonomes qui n'ont pas du tout dans
l'emploi donc c'est difficile de
vraiment avoir une ligne générale pour
tout le monde pour encadrement la
situation de la personne quels sont les
revenus et jusqu'à quel point la
situation le vraiment très très qui
apporte son lot de malheurs on va
célébrer chose comment les situations
impacte les personnes et on trouve les
solutions évoquées et combien de temps
ça peut prendre trouver les solutions
par écouter ça peut prendre une couple
d'heures dans certains corps on a des
causes non les gens tels dans nos
centres téléphoniques pour nous et rick
taylor
on a des difficultés et on trouve des
solutions des gens présents dans nos
points de service pour
avec nos conseillers conseillère les
gens trouvent des solutions aussi tant
qu'indépendant quelque chose qu'on dit
on va vous revenir dans un monde de ou 3
notre message aux gens c'est vraiment on
se met en mode solution souvent on est
déjà en contact avec des entreprises
aussi où on imagine qu'elles vont avoir
des difficultés donc on est trop actif
on les appelle on en a pas on n'a pas
annoncé les mesures d'allongement allez
vous réduire d'autres types de frais ou
intérêt je pense aux frais bancaires ou
hautaine aux taux d'intérêt sur les
cartes de crédit par écouter
actuellement la situation on doit
prendre des années dizaines de diffusion
par jour on a annoncé cette semaine
vraiment notre volonté de réduire notre
nombre de points de service pour
justement contribuer à freiner la
propagation de virus est aussi de mettre
en place des meilleures mesures
d'allègement on annonce aujourd'hui vous
allez voir aujourd'hui ou demain a
montré qu'on va permettre le paiement
sans contact sur nos terminaux points de
vente dans les dépanneurs les pharmacies
les épiceries au lieu d'un maximum de
100 dollars ça va être 250 dollars pour
que les gens que se retire et parfois de
l'argent ou d' plus rapidement et elle
est toute mesure pourrait être annoncée
prochainement
on vraiment on suit la situation dans la
narration originale qu'ont sur les
marges de crédit sur les cartes de
crédit sur une victoire des cartes de
crédit le retrait le retrait le retrait
jusqu'à 250 $ là pour défendre sans
contact m sur les cartes et on va voir
sur les cartes et donc pas de changement
sur les taux d'intérêt ce le dis pas
pour l'instant on suit au jour dernier
point la solidité financière de
desjardins la schl rachète des blocs
d'obligations ça a été annoncé
qu'est ce qui se passe de votre côté là
dessus à écouter notre côté on entre on
a une capitalisation milliards d'éviter
qu'ils sont très très bonne donc
aujourd'hui la situation et de capital
et vicky du mouvement desjardins est en
étant très bonne prochain
pour monique en contact avec la banque
du canada avec les autorités
gouvernementales
ils ont fait des annonces cette semaine
alors moi je tiens à rassurer nos
membres le système le système financier
solide et le mouvement desjardins
merci beaucoup monsieur cormier ton ces
quelques minutes ce soir
merci monsieur fils est enfin de retour